we have occupied police headquarters for
the past I think week or so demanding
justice for Angelo school
one of the things certainly as a lawyer
it's easier for me to navigate my rights
but before they see me as a lawyer they
see me as a black man and I've been a
black man longer than I've been a lawyer
and so that filters through a lot of my
experience the seem like oh there's a
pretty strong systemic root of violence
within Canada against indigenous peoples
and then just people of color in general
like globally Toronto especially has had
a long history of brutality against
indigenous people women of color queer
trans folk and black lives black male
lives especially the list is huge here
in the city